c'est parti aller où la truffe appelle
le temps d'enlever la laine est-ce que
ce labrador trouve en quelques instants
le diamant noir
ma chérie stoppe l'odeur est tellement
puissante qu'elle se répand dans un
rayon de 10 cm regarde ma chérie
regarde la truffe regarde comme elle est
belle
tu es bien ma chérie
c'est quoi c'est l'osmose entre un arbre
et un champignon un champignon
souterrain donc l'arbre apporte à ce
champignon des nutriments et en
contrepartie donc le mycélium de
champignon
apporte aide à l'arbre à se nourrir
également
et
particulièrement
il y a 15 ans se sont lancés dans
l'aventure en plantant des arbres
truffiers aujourd'hui ils sont une
trentaine à cultiver la truffe du Loiret
il faut qu'elle soit vraiment bien noir
et après on vérifiera si la truffe et
bien mûr pas mieux s'il y a pas des
bactéries si si elle est bonne à la
vente aujourd'hui les producteurs du
Loiret sont réunis dans une association
locale afin de promouvoir leurs produits
qui d'après eux n'a rien à envier à la
truffe noire du Périgord
un sol argilo-calcaire avec un péage de
huit donc à se développe très bien et le
parfum de sel du Périgord et peut-être
que avec les saisons avec le temps qui
est moins froid l'hiver on a les mêmes
l'attitude que le Périgord pour avoir
pour avoir ce champignon souterrain et
preuve de son succès le premier marché
de la truffe du Loiret aura lieu le 15
janvier à Orléans